[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[CLUCKING]
[CROWING]
[ALARM BELL]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[RATCHETING]
[HAIRDRYER WHINE]
[MOTORCYCLE KICK-START SOUNDS]
[BICYCLE BELL]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[SQUEAKING]
[TYPEWRITER CLACKING]
[RECORD SCRATCHING SOUNDS]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[DING]
[CHOPPING SOUNDS]
[CHAINSAW SOUNDS]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[RECORD SCRATCH]
[WHOOSH]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HENDERSON: So
hello, everybody.
As the video shows, things
get better over time.
Technology helps
things get better.
It helps things get smaller,
faster, easier, much
much better.
But how about apps?
How will the architecture
of apps get better?
We're here to tell you
more about our vision
for the future of Android
app development, discovery,
and distribution.
Android's first 10
years have centered
around the app download.
It works like this.
Developers build a large app
with all their features in it.
People find apps on Google Play
and install the ones they want.
And then they wait while Play
sends the app to their device.
And it's been a great 10 years.
There are now over 2
billion active Android
devices around the world.
And Play installed close to
100 billion apps and games
in the last year--
100 billion.
But our app model
can get even better.
So what to improve?
Well, during development,
building and publishing
for different device
types is still hard.
In the discovery
stage, new users
are put off by long wait
times for the download.
And after distribution,
large apps sizes--
these large apps are much more
likely to get uninstalled.
So the future of apps will
address these problems.
Development will
be more modular.
Discovery will be more instant.
And distribution
will be more dynamic.
Our first step in this
direction has been Instant Apps
and you'll hear
more today about how
it's removing install
friction and helping
to improve discovery.
We've made Instant Apps
available to game developers
at GDC this year.
You can simply tap
the Try Now button
to jump into game
experiences like this one,
"King's Candy Crush Saga."
Developers are seeing
that Instant Apps
drives incremental installs.
Users that would have otherwise
abandoned, at this page,
are trying the experience,
they're clicking Try Now,
and then they're
proceeding to install.
Today, we're revealing
our related efforts
on development and distribution.
In the developer
keynote, you heard
a little bit about what we're
working on in these areas.
And we're going to talk
much more about them now.
To tell you more about
what we've been working on,
let me invite out Milena,
Engineering Manager
for Play App Distribution,
and Kobi Product Manager
for Play App Distribution.
[APPLAUSE]
KOBI GLICK: Thanks, Matt.
The Android ecosystem has
evolved since the humble G1
was introduced 10 years ago.
With over two billion
devices, there
are new form factors and
thousands of new device models
every year.
This is great for user choice.
There is a device for everyone.
But thinking about
all these devices
has made development complex.
Some of you use multi APK to
optimize the size of your app.
This is costly and complicated.
Instead of focusing on
making your app unique,
you end up focusing on trying
to target the right devices.
With Multi APKs, the dimensions
of device configurations
on Android multiply
really quickly.
So if you try to optimize by
CPU architecture and stream
densities, you will
end up with many APKs.
And the number of APKs will
grow really, really quickly,
especially when you
start targeting 64-bit.
And each one of those APKs has
its own unique version code,
although you release all of
them as part of the same app
release.
This is painful for developers.
There must be a better way.
To avoid the hassle
of multi APK,
some apps simply ship everything
to everyone, all screen
densities, all CPU
architectures, all languages.
The result are really,
really big apps.
This is painful for users.
MILENA NIKOLIC: There
must be a better way.
Supporting all the
different devices,
while also adding new
features, has also
contributed to apps
becoming larger over time.
Since March 2012,
the average APK size
has grown by five times.
This is bad for users because
mobile data and device storage
are both at a premium,
and users don't
want to have to wait forever to
start using an app or a game.
We can't reiterate
this point enough.
APK size has a very real
effect on conversion
and successful
download of your app.
This graph shows
you the correlation
between user conversion
in a Play Store listing
and the size of an APK.
Clearly, the heavier
your app, the less likely
a user will download it.
You may have read about
this in one of our media
posts on this topic.
For every six megabytes of
an increase in APK size,
the conversion rate
goes down by 1%.
This is a material loss
in conversion rate,
which can be recovered by
focusing on the APK size.
But that's not all.
Bloated APKs can also
be bad for innovation.
Some developers are
having to choose
between adding new features
and keeping their apps lean.
For example, Flipkart is a
leading e-commerce player
in India, where data
costs are still high.
So it's important for them
to keep their app download
size small.
They're looking for solutions
to keep their initial install
as small as possible,
while being able to provide
rich experiences for their
users in the long run.
So we've been
thinking about this.
How can we decrease APK size
without affecting development
and distribution complexity?
Well, let's look at
what's in today's APK.
Many languages, most of
which a user never needs.
Duplicative CPU
information for ARM and x86
and, sometimes, even
32-bit and 64-bit.
It includes resources in five or
six different screen densities.
And it probably includes niche
or experimental features,
which only a percentage
of the audience
will ever be exposed to.
This doesn't make much sense.
A far better solution would
be to only deliver the code
and resources that a
particular device needs,
and to deliver a leaner
app experience, where
users could download
additional features on demand.
KOBI GLICK: So our vision
for solving this pain
point in development
is a new app format.
I'm happy to announce that today
we're launching the Android App
Bundle.
The Android App Bundle is
the new publishing format
for Android.
It is open source and
backward compatible.
It will help your users
benefit from smaller apps.
And you will not need to
build multi APK to optimize
the size of your apps anymore.
Yes, you heard that right,
multi APK is finally going away.
[APPLAUSE]
MILENA NIKOLIC: Nice.
Thank you.
KOBI GLICK: With the App Bundle,
you only build one thing.
And you don't need to refactor
your code to start using it.
In addition, it enables
modular app development,
which we'll talk about
later in this session.
So how does this
work on Google Play?
For end users to benefit
from the app bundle,
we're doing some of the heavy
lifting behind the scene,
on the distribution side.
We called this Google
Play innovation launching
today Dynamic Delivery.
With Dynamic Delivery, Play
will take your up bundle
and generate APKs that are
specific to a device, with only
the code and resources
needed by that device.
This means much smaller
apps for your users,
which is great news for the
billions of new users coming
online.
So let's take a look at
the Android App Bundle
in a little bit more detail.
MILENA NIKOLIC: So here
is an Android App Bundle.
As you can see, it is
quite similar to an APK.
It has DEX files, resources,
assets, and native libraries.
But one difference you can
see is that it can also
include more than one module--
in this particular example,
Base, Foo, and Bar.
This is important for
app modularity, which
we'll get to talk about soon.
Another thing you can see
is that the format includes
a few metadata files,
where you can provide
Play with different instructions
on how to process the bundle.
Now, how does Google
Play use this format
to create the
lightweight binary?
We use an Android platform
feature, launched in Lollipop,
called split APKs.
If you think about Android App
Bundle as a publishing format,
splits are the serving format
and what eventually ends up
being installed on user devices.
When you upload
your bundle to Play,
we will process it
to generate splits.
We do this with a tool we
have very originally named
Bundle Tool.
This tool will be
open source, so you
can use it to perform
the same processing
that we do for off-Play testing
and distribution purposes.
Bundle Tool facilitates all
the necessary conversions
between a bundle
format and split APKs,
for example, generating all
the splits for densities,
architectures, and
even languages,
selecting specific splits
needed by a particular device,
installing splits on
a connected device,
and, for devices on Android
versions older than Lollipop,
it facilitates fusing of
splits into monolithic
device-optimized APKs.
There are many more options
available with the bundle
and the Bundle Tool.
In the next session, at
stage two, at 6:00 PM,
our engineering team will
provide a technical deep dive
about the bundle format,
the Bundle Tool, and all
the options it enables.
KOBI GLICK: OK, so you
mentioned size savings.
Tell me a little bit more
about how it happens.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Sure.
So the big difference
between splits and multi APK
are that splits are
additive not multiplicative.
For example, the app here has
the base APK with DEX files,
and the corresponding density,
API, and language splits.
With Dynamic Delivery, Play
will only deliver the density
and API splits required
by a particular device,
making the app
smaller for users.
In addition, Play
will start handling
a new dimension, languages.
In the Android App
Bundle, you will
be able to supply
all the languages.
And Play will only send to
users the splits for languages
they're typically using.
In the rare case where a user
switches to a new language,
that we weren't
aware of before, Play
will dynamically
deliver relevant splits
to their device.
For some apps,
language splits alone
introduce massive size savings.
KOBI GLICK: So we've
been testing you with--
we've been testing this
with a few developers.
Probably, some of you are
in the audience, right now.
For example, Twitter is one
of our early access partners.
By splitting over languages
and string densities,
they are saving 35%
of their app size.
This is huge.
And this is not everything.
Here are a few more examples--
text+ with 26% size savings,
Blue Apron with 27% size
savings, and Jaumo
with 50% size savings.
MILENA NIKOLIC:
And that's not all.
We have more.
Here a few more examples of
our early access partners.
All these partners
have built the bundle,
published it to Play, and
were able to make their apps
significantly smaller.
Look at the results.
ABA English, Airbnb, LinkedIn,
Memorise, Perigee, Pluto TV,
and RV AppStudios have all
saved between 11% and 64%
of their app size.
And that's how Android App
Bundle and Google Play's
Dynamic Delivery work.
Once you publish and
build your bundle,
Google Play will deliver just
what the specific device needs.
Now, let me invite Karen, who
leads Android Studio Product
Team, to the stage, to
tell you a little bit more
about how you build a bundle.
[APPLAUSE]
KAREN NG: Thanks, Milena.
Hi, I'm Karen.
And I work on the Android Team.
SPEAKER: The sound
is really bad, guys.
[LAUGHTER]
KOBI GLICK: The sound
is indeed really bad.
KAREN NG: Those are the best
moments, when the mic is still
on in the back stage.
So you've now seen the
concept of an app bundle.
What I want to do
is pivot directions
and show you a bit
about the tools
that you're going to use
to build the app bundle.
In Android Studio
3.2 Canary that
was released less
than four hours ago--
so go download it--
there is full support,
inside Studio and Gradle,
to build the app bundle format.
The app bundle will contain
everything your app needs,
all your languages, support
for every device screen,
every hardware architecture, and
will automatically build those
into configurations,
those configurations
into APKs for you.
If you're using Android
Studio to build a bundle,
the flow will feel very similar
to working with an APK today.
What we've introduced
in the Build menu
is a new option
to build a bundle.
If you're using a continuous
integration system,
all the Gradle
build-tasks have also
been updated to build a bundle.
So replacing a single option,
rebuilding your project,
as a bundle, means
that's all you
need to do to take advantage
of the APK size savings.
You'll also be able to take
advantage of Google Play's
Dynamic Delivery, so only
the bits that are needed
are downloaded to the device.
The Android App Bundle is
your new publishing format
for the Store.
Testing and
deploying your bundle
will, again, feel
very similar to it
what it does today
in Android Studio.
You're just working with APKs.
What we've also done is updated
the new run configuration
dialog, so you can
choose the bundle
and select your
deployment target
and deploy directly to a
device or to an emulator.
Gradle will build
the bundle, and then
deploy only the APKs that
are needed by the device.
This ability to test
and deploy your bundle
will simulate exactly
what the Play Store does.
If you're just testing
your app functionality,
though, you can go ahead and
use an APK like you did before.
It'll work the same way.
And it's actually going to be
faster to deploy the device.
To upload the bundle
into the Play Store,
you'll need to sing the
bundle with a signing key.
For all existing apps,
you need to provide
Google Play with
your signing key,
so Play can process that key
and then resign your bundle
with the same key.
For new apps, Play will just
generate that key for you.
If you recall, in
a multi APK world,
you used to have to
upload every APK,
manually, yourself,
to that Store.
In a bundle world, we do all
the heavy lifting for you.
You only have to
upload one thing.
KOBI GLICK: Once you
build the bundle,
you can upload and publish
it through the Play Console.
You will use the same
release flow you're
familiar with, with an APK.
In addition, in order
to test your app bundle,
with your testers, you can use
our new internal testing track.
It allows you to distribute
your app to your testers
within less than a minute.
When you publish in a
bundle, to the Play Console,
we provide you a new way
to look at your App bundle
and understand the size of
the device-specific APKs
that Play generates and
delivers to your users.
We call this new page
the Bundle Explorer.
Here, you can see
what is the size
of all those device-specific
APKs case that Play generates
for every device configuration.
For example, you
can see, what is
the size of the APKs that Play
will deliver to an ARM XHDPI
device?
You can also use
this page to download
the device-specific
APKs generated
by Play to any
device model that is
listed in our device catalog.
KAREN NG: We showed you how the
Android App Bundle and Dynamic
Delivery will benefit
you in a number of ways.
For developers, you
really no longer
have to manage the
multi APK world.
For your users,
we're really hoping
that they won't
have to pay the cost
of that giant, upfront install.
So what does it all
mean in practice?
We worked with a
number of developers
in an early access program,
as Kobi mentioned earlier.
And it's been fun.
Twitter has told us what
they like about the new flow.
With the Android App Bundle,
they upload one binary,
with one version code,
and Dynamic Delivery
handles API, density,
and language splits.
For Twitter to have
done this themselves,
it would have required the
maintenance of 500 APKs.
That's not a small feat.
They described their
build and release process
as more streamlined, with
the size of their app
has significantly
decreased for their users.
So you've now seen how
building an app bundle
results in smaller apps.
And it also means
that you no longer
have to manage multiple APKs.
The second big change that
the app bundle enables
is more modular apps.
So today, we're releasing
a preview of the ability
to deliver features on demand.
Just as building a
bundle automatically
builds splits, such a language,
screen density, and hardware,
you can create a split
for additional features.
We call these features
Dynamic Features.
And they are
installed on demand.
Each app will then have
a base feature and n
number of dynamic features.
Again, with the latest
version of Android Studio,
you can start creating apps
today with Dynamic Features.
If you want to publish that
app into the Play Store,
however, we're still
in beta, so you'll
need to join the beta
program on the Play Store.
Although most apps won't need
any effort to create the bundle
and support Dynamic Delivery,
creating these modular apps,
with on demand features, we do
expect will be a longer term
progression.
And it works best as you
re-architect your apps over
time.
So let me give you an example
of what it means for an app
to have Dynamic Features.
In this particular example,
we have a Camera Depot app.
Its just a simple
e-commerce app.
There's four features
to pay attention to.
The first feature is
just to be able to browse
goods, the second one, to
be able to see what offers
you have, third,
being the buy items,
and the fourth
being able to sell.
You can imagine that,
from our app's usage,
that we see that less
than 1% of people
ever use the sell feature.
And its only by people in a
particular region or primarily.
Every person who
downloaded your app
has to pay the price of
installing all the features.
In this case, we should make the
sell feature a dynamic feature.
So if a user clicks
on the Sell button,
you'll see a small user
prompt that the feature is
downloading, and
then it's dynamically
delivered to the device.
So how do these dynamic features
then relate to a bundle?
In the e-commerce app, the
main browse application
today was what we would
call a base feature.
You can then extend
your base feature
with dynamic features
that deliver to your users
on demand.
In Android Studio, we've
added a new plugin,
called Dynamic Feature.
You can extend your
application in Android studio
by adding multiple
Dynamic Features to it.
So let's take another example.
Imagine that you have
a video chat app.
And the main app would
be your base feature.
You can then carve
out a special feature,
like augmented reality stickers,
and deliver it on demand
to users only with devices
with the right camera
to support that feature.
If you build a new app,
you should design your app
as modular from the
start, thinking carefully
about a lightweight
base app experience,
and then how you would extend
that app with Dynamic Features.
If you have an
existing app, we're
expecting to see people take
advantage of Dynamic Features
but carve out specific
features over time.
So once you've created
your Dynamic Features,
you can choose to deploy only
a set of them to the device.
As you can see here, in
Android Studio, what we've done
is we've also updated
how you deploy.
The box, here, shows you
three Dynamic Features,
Buy, Offers, and Sell.
You have full control over
which features you deploy.
So that you can
mix and match them.
And the base feature
is always deployed.
KOBI GLICK: So
this framework will
help large apps become
smaller and small apps
remain small, while
adding more functionality.
The first step is building
an Android App Bundle.
And the next step, like
Karen just described,
is identifying features
that can be carved out
as Dynamic Features.
After refactoring
your code to carve out
those dynamic
features, you will need
to integrate with a new client
library we're releasing today.
It's called the Google
Play Core Library,
and it includes a
set of APIs allowing
you to manage the delivery
of those Dynamic Features
to your users.
And in case you want
to deliver a feature
as a response to a user
request, you probably
want to build a nice user
experience around it.
The Google Play Core Library
provides a high degree
of flexibility when
you want to deliver
a feature to your users.
Beyond delivering a feature, as
a response to a user request,
you can also ask to prefetch
a feature, when you predict
the user will need
it soon, or you
can ask Play to deliver
the feature as part
of the next update cycle.
We call this option
Deferred Installation.
When thinking about good use
cases for Dynamic Features,
we've identified two
broad categories.
The first category is what
we call distinct features.
These features are logically
separate from the main flow
of your app.
For example, in the e-commerce
app Karen mentioned earlier,
there is a buyer experience
and a seller experience.
The seller experience
is logically
separate and, therefore, a
great candidate for a Dynamic
Feature.
The second category is what
we call interrupting features.
Those features pop up during
normal user flow in your app.
For example, if you
have a photography app,
you might have an option
to add additional filters
during the editing process.
This is what we call an
interrupting feature.
And for those features,
it is typically better
to use the deferred installation
option I mentioned earlier,
to make sure users have
the feature available
when they are ready to use it.
And of course, we'll
be super curious
to see what use cases you come
up with as you start innovating
with Dynamic Features.
Earlier in this
talk, we've mentioned
how developers want to
keep their base install
as small as possible, while
building rich, new user
experiences.
Flipkart and Facebook are two
of our early access partners
who are helping us to
test dynamic features.
For Flipkart, as they think
about building for the next 100
million users,
Dynamic Features allow
them to ship new and rich
user experiences that
are naturally size-heavy, like
vernacular support, video,
and fees.
Facebook uses Dynamic Features
to improve the experience
of the app for
different devices,
while reducing its network
and resource usage.
They told us that
one thing they really
like about the new
framework is how
Dynamic Features are updated
seamlessly as part of any up
update.
Dynamic Features enable
dynamic code loading
when you deliver a feature
on demand to your user,
it can include code,
resources, and assets.
As you know, apps on Play are
scanned by Google Play Protect
and delivered securely
to user devices.
Dynamic Features will also be
scanned by Google Play Protect,
which means your
users will benefit
from all the same protections
we've been building
for years on Google Play.
KAREN NG: The Android App Bundle
will make development easier
and is the future of
the Android app model.
Dynamic delivery will
improve distribution.
But what about the big
thing in the middle?
We've barely touched
upon discovery.
JONATHAN KARMEL: I want to
invite Jonathan Karmel, who
leads the Instant Apps
Team, to come join me
and to tell us a little
bit more about discovery.
SPEAKER: There you go.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN KARMEL: Thanks.
Thanks, Karen.
Whoa.
Last year, on this
stage, we announced
that all app developers can
now develop an instant app.
Today, we're excited to
add games to the mix.
Today, all game developers can
now develop an instant app.
So let's start with an
example of one of our top game
developers that are alive today.
Roll the video, please.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Google
Play Instant, where
you can get apps and
now games instantly.
And as you saw in the video,
when you click Try Now,
you'll launch into a native
app experience that is instant.
And then you'll have
an option to install.
And users are installing more
because of this Try Now button.
Let me explain how.
In the old world, you'd
see a Store listing page
like this, where the user
has two options, Install
or abandon.
And users were abandoning,
because they weren't
ready to commit to 100
megs onto their phone
without playing the game or
understanding the game fully.
But in the new world,
it now looks like this.
So if you are already coming
to the Store to install,
you're going to continue to
install at the same rate you
have before.
And we're seeing this.
The CTR rate for
Install has not changed.
But if you were starting to
wander and think about leaving,
you now have another option.
You have the Try Now button.
And that will launch you
into the Instant Experience
and allow you to install.
So where do you see these
Instant Experiences?
Well, clearly, from
the Play Store,
where you'll see not only
Try Now, but collections
and banners that launch
directly into an instant app.
But the opportunity that
we talked about, last year,
was nothing to do
with the Play Store.
It was everything
outside the Play Store
because that's often
where the decision is
to install or abandon,
and that's where
the biggest drop-off rates are.
Let's take ads for example.
In the old world,
I click this ad,
and I'd land in the
Store listing page
with an option to install.
In the new world,
I click this, and I
land in the Instant Experience,
with an option to install.
In both worlds, I have to decide
if I want to install or not,
but now I get to play the
game while I assess if this
is worth it to be on my phone.
And if I receive an
SMS from a friend that
says, try out this
new TV show, I
can start watching that
TV show immediately,
and then decide if I
want to install the app.
And if I'm looking for a
new home on Google Search,
I can actually find the
home, land in the experience,
look at the images, assess
if I like the property,
and then determine
if I want to install
the app, the real
estate app that
got me all that information.
Now, this is great.
It's a consumer
first experience.
It's great for the user.
But is it good for developers?
The answer is yes.
We're seeing installs,
convergence, and engagement
go up.
So let's start with installs.
"Mighty Battle" saw an
19% increase in installs
just from the Try Now button.
Now, this is one of the higher
data points that we've seen.
But we have seen incremental
installs across the board.
And as a developer, as you
expand beyond the Play Store
and start thinking
about all the traffic
sources I showed
on the other slide,
you'll start noticing that
your new customer acquisition
channel is instant apps.
Take Vimeo, for example, which
is sitting right over here.
They're seeing 15% of
their installs coming
from instant apps.
And NOS, a news app, is seeing
30% of their installs coming
from instant apps.
This is their new customer
acquisition channel.
So are instant apps just
driving users to install?
No, they're also having great
experiences for the user
within the instant app.
Wego, a travel app, is seeing
27% increase in convergence
within the travel app,
where you get new paid
leads from the instant app.
And Viki, a TV show app, is
seeing monetizable watch time
increase by 5x.
So be it, if you're
trying to drive installs,
or you want to make
sure that the user has
a great experience
within the instant app,
instant apps are doing both.
Now, I know what
you're wondering.
We just talked about
Android App Bundle.
We talked about instant apps.
And now you're
worried that you're
going to have double the work.
You're going to go home and
have to work on both things.
Or you're going to have to
choose one or the other.
Absolutely not.
This is part of the same effort.
An instant is just the mode
of the Android App Bundle.
So what I'm going to do is take
you from an Android App Bundle
and migrate it to an
instant-enabled Android App
Bundle.
And then I'm also going to
start with an instant app
and show you how you get
to the Android App Bundle.
All right, so Kobi came up here
and said, you take your APK,
and you get to an
Android App Bundle.
And then he also
mentioned that you're
going to start carving
out code and start
modularizing your app.
So as you go through
this process,
you might notice that
one of your features
makes a great entry point.
And you would love that your
users actually instantly jump
into your app that way.
So, if your base module and
your dynamic feature module
are small enough, you can just
make those instant enabled.
And for all that code that
is in your installed app
that you're not ready to have
part of your instant app,
you're going to wrap that
as a dynamic feature module,
and you're just going to make
it available at install time.
And there you have
it, one binary
that is both an instant
app and an installed app.
Now let's see what
this looks like
if you're one of the
instant app developers
that I see in the
audience today.
So you probably have something
that looks like this.
You have a zip file.
It has both a base feature
module, potentially another
feature module.
And you're going to take--
and you did all this hard work
to decrease the
binary, to modularize.
That work is not wasted.
You're just going to
take that same code,
and you're just going to make it
part of the Android App Bundle.
And for all that code that's
in your Installed app, that's
not in your instant
app, again, you're
going to wrap it as a
dynamic feature module,
and just make sure it's
available at install time.
There you are.
Again, you have
one binary that's
both an instant app
and installed app.
So now Karen's going
to talk about what
this looks like in Android
Studio and the tooling that
is coming soon to
help you do just that.
KAREN NG: Thanks, Jonathan.
So let's take the same
view of the app bundle
that we saw earlier.
If you're going to relate
it, an instant app,
and relate it to an
Android App Bundle,
what would that look like?
So as Jonathan
mentioned, at this point,
you already have a
pretty modular app,
built using the existing
Android Studio plug-ins.
You have a base feature and
a set of feature modules.
It relates really nicely
to the Android App Bundle.
The only difference is that
your base feature is now
com.android.application, and
that your feature modules are
just using the Gradle plug-in,
com.android.dynamic-feature.
In the future,
we'll be releasing
tooling to support full
unification of these two
formats.
Your Android App Bundle will
simply be instant-enabled.
So regardless of
where you start from,
if it's an instant app moving
to an Android App Bundle
or an Android App Bundle that
wants to be instant-enabled,
you're going to be covered.
So as I mentioned
earlier, dynamic features,
you can build them today in
Android Studio, building apps
with dynamic features.
But if you do want to
publish them to production,
they're still
available as preview,
and you need to join the beta
program on the Play Store.
At the same time that we're
releasing dynamic features
and making them fully
available, we'll
also be working on the tooling
to instant-enable your app
bundle.
Now let me invite
Matt back up here
to talk more about the future.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT HENDERSON: Thanks.
So we've talked about
big changes coming today.
Firstly, much leaner
apps are possible,
and there's no more multi APK.
And secondly, dynamic
features are out as a beta.
Now I'd like to encourage
you to imagine how you'll
use these capabilities in the
future and make use of them
for your own app.
So as you've heard, using the
Android App Bundle and Google
Play Dynamic Delivery, you'll
be able to create highly
configurable,
modularized apps that
can be adapted to different
users and different use cases.
So your preliminary experience
can be lean and instant,
with additional features
provided to users, on demand,
as they need it.
Which of your
features are only used
by a fraction of your users?
The capabilities will allow you
to create different versions
of the same feature for
different device types,
such as low memory and
high memory devices.
It will also enable you
to do live experimentation
with different versions
of the same functionality
without making your app bigger.
And you can find out which
variant works the best
and fuels your success.
What sensitive user journeys in
your app, like a checkout path,
could benefit from that
sort of experimentation?
We're moving away from a
world of giant installs
to a world of modular app
development, instant app
experiences, and
dynamic delivery.
Apps will be richer, yet they'll
be smaller and more efficient,
both on disk and over the wire.
We encourage you
to start thinking
about how you'll use these
capabilities to improve
your install conversion, start
thinking about how you'll
use these capabilities to
lower your uninstall rates,
and start thinking about how
you'll use them to build richer
experiences that help
you to improve engagement
with your app.
Android apps are evolving.
And we're excited
to see what you can
build with these capabilities.
And we start today.
All developers can now
build Android App Bundles,
in the latest Canary release
of Android Studio 3.2,
and upload them to
the Play Console.
You don't need to refactor
your app to get started.
You can get started on the
web at g.co/androidAppBundle.
And you can get started with
modularization and dynamic
features in the Canary, too.
Those who are ready
to start publishing
apps with dynamic
features can apply
to join the beta on the website.
To find out more, attend the
session right after this one,
on stage two, where our
engineering team are going
to share some technical
deep-dives about building
the bundle and using
the new client library,
enabling dynamic delivery.
Thanks, and have a great IO.
[APPLAUSE]
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]